thanks for coming in how are you I'm
good now that you're here oh it's good
it's good to talk to you so let's talk
about this album and the approach to
this album yeah you sort of look at
things in life and then you flip it on
your head and you look at it from the
positive perspective try to yeah much as
you can where does that come from
um I don't know I think honestly I was
kind of I think it kind of came out that
way I also like I was raised to believe
that like even struggles are there to
make you stronger so if you think that
that's how life is then even when you
get hit with a difficulty you see it in
a certain light are you they optimistic
about it you realize they're like life
coaches that work their whole life just
to figure it out you're putting albums
out the people can just have at home
yeah I love music that actually that you
can like use right like that you put on
and you're like oh man this one makes me
feel a certain way whether that for any
reason whether it's like you know you
have a break up and need something sad
like go put that on and this album naive
I think you put on when you're trying to
pick yourself back up or going through
something then you you the extra push
talk about that talk about naive and
sort of what sort of theme and anthem
and where were you in your life when you
needed to write an album like this mhm I
was just kind of like struggling to find
the magic I knew I had some good songs
but I was like really searching for you
know now that this is my fourth album
there's a lot of pressure a lot of like
he just gets bigger and bigger and
bigger
yeah you can't help but not feel like
man there's more but bigger you get
there's more expectation and that
doesn't really help when you're creating
alright alright you're supposed to go in
to find out something that feels good or
that's amazing and I just couldn't seem
to find it so from a place of like kind
of struggle and desperation I wrote a
song called don't give up on me which is
really such a beautiful song thank you
so much and you know from me being
honest about where I was at then people
that are going through that it's been
like resonating like crazy
mm-hm another song called my own hero
which is about like you know just like
going together and making something
happen yeah I sent that song to a girl
friend of mine who's going through some
stuff and just like text it to her and
I'll have a listen
hello this is your anthem this is just a
shot so you know and then the title of
naive is all about I am a positive guy
and I shall try to show up to each
action and situation with a positive
outlook and sometimes in a cynical world
the person that does that is seen as
stupid this scene is like oh I smiling
so much I like don't you know the world
is like crappy right hey chill with all
your positive
ridiculousness isn't that pretty sad
that that's sometimes and it can't be
all the time because a lot more people
embracing what your Lobby where you put
that it you know it's been my life story
as the positive guy is sometimes you'll
get undercut is like oh yeah
but you don't really know what's going
on right and so this is a kind of a
rebellious like I'm in on the joke I
know what some sometimes get said about
people like me it's really more written
for like people who are like me that
should like to show up situations
positively and are trying to make a
change sometimes light yeah people the
light breakers you know I'm saying and
so those of you like kind of my shows
and this is an album for them yeah I
mean it's a little grittier than than
other albums right and and I think you
can definitely hear that is that
something you wanted to give your
audience or was it just that just
happened now it's kind of where I was
like enjoying chasing the sound you know
there's like more choirs on this more
organic instruments and yeah the gritty
things just happened to be where I was
where I was at what's your approach to
right I think how long did this one take
in comparison to the other albums
usually when I look back at at the songs
I like right out every day that I read a
song and the number and stuff it's
usually about a hundred that seems to be
where I have to get to to then pick that
11 a 100 to then pick the 13 that feel
like those are all great you know it's
thinking like when I have an idea it
feels so real like if you if you have a
memory if ever does before a memory of
like a story in your life to you you
know what it is and then you start to
tell the story and while you're telling
the person the starting be like oh this
isn't as good it felt different like a
lot of what songwriting is and I'm
getting better you know hopefully you
get better at songwriting but to get to
the a-plus-plus songs you first have to
have an inspiration to feeling then you
go to do it and most the time it falls
apart like sand in your hands when you
get it out there there's like every once
in a while you get some that just come
out okay and are still intact yeah and
then you give those to everybody else so
you
listen to your gut on those but is there
a person in your family or someone in
your camp or oh yeah me and my manager
you know he's the one I send the music
to and my wife as well she's great she's
got a good ear got a good ear had
honestly and babies I when I was a
street performer you were always knew
you were on to something if you get like
if the toddlers came around and they
couldn't they had no idea what's going
on but they're just like yeah you're in
a good spot that's actually very very
true speaking of which
on America's Got Talent not a toddler oh
but a young man so coool played your
song on his violin right yeah okay what
was that like did you know that he was
going to do that and I had no idea I
just woke up and then you know all my
social media stuff was going bonkers
because he leukemia decided he still
want to play the violin and he learned
and he was like jumping around dancing
to it and then they put don't give up on
me in the package next to him so when
they hit the golden buzzer it was like
don't give up on me and all this
craziness and so I've invited me I think
he said he's gonna come on to her play
amazing in a moment like that then has a
resurgence for things like it just that
song gets pushed pushed back out again
the truth is like songs like don't give
up on me they they can they have
something about them that people like or
that helps or gives to the perth to the
listener so i've been finding that it
just keeps having its own little life of
its own in different situations we had
this video go crazy where i sang with a
group of kids behind me at a choir in
Long Island a kids choir and that one
took off on Facebook I couldn't even
like sing it cause it was so beautiful
this choir director orchestrated like a
bunch of voices behind me and has to try
to say if you if you get a chance that's
amazing so you you touched on something
earlier so you've always sort of been
like this yeah the positive light the
guy who finds that who's that from in
your family usually that comes from
someone is that your mom is that your
dad is it a grandparent is it well my my
father's a children's singer Yeah right
which is pretty bubbly and sweet and if
you've ever been to one of his shows
it's like oh my god there's like all
these kids that are like wide-eyed when
he's teaching his album is called like
teaching piece this is where I come from
so you think my blood and my mother is
incredibly
wonderful they would write the album's
together so I just kind of like grew up
learning about this and then I think
what you're getting on the fourth album
is as you get older yeah like the guy
that is raised that way then is hit with
cynicism and and what does that sound
like and what are you doing yeah what do
you do that and it sounds like a lot of
like war rally cries to stay positive
honestly right yeah